my name is sarah semaphore i work in
cambodia for an organization social
enterprise called friends also national
working with marginalized by mentioning
the new indication is really at the core
of everything we do so the question to
me is very important is how to repair a
meeting as ensure access to education
and I think that access is less and less
an issue there are more and more and
more young people children going to
school and for me the most important
point is how can we make sure that they
stay in school as long as possible to
get the best education and for this for
me the answer would be to work with the
family the family is essential and the
family must be able to cover the cost of
that education which is often very
expensive and the family must believe in
the importance of education so if we
work with a family structure to support
your child for school that's how we will
reach object